félicité welcome to the front-runners
I'm so happy that you're here I thank
you for having me you are going to see
an orange chair that is our frontrunner
chair so watch your head and take a seat
félicité welcome to the show thanks so
much for being here I like so many
people and so impressed with your
performance is Jane Hawking in the
theory of everything do you feel like
this was the most demanding film role
that you've taken on absolutely and
because I was playing a real person and
knowing that they are going to be seeing
it at some point really raises the
stakes and because I was telling this
woman's story over 25 years it felt like
okay I'm gonna need a lot of time to
prepare for this and to really
understand all the all the emotional
shifts throughout her character over
those years right now you're at such a
high in your career and so much acclaim
for this performance is there an
experience that you had earlier in your
career that made you think that you
could really be on to something special
with acting it would have to be when I
worked with a director called Drake
doremus we made a film called like crazy
together and that was that was a very
special film because it was it was the
first time I'd worked in Los Angeles
it's that one of the first times I've
even been to Los Angeles and it was that
working with someone who worked in a way
that I'd never experienced before it was
different about it it was always really
closed small sets intimate sets only a
few people around not not breaking it up
you know doing lots of makeup and hair
checks it was very much just
concentrated time just to get involved
in the scenes and I haven't really
worked that way before and and also it
was improvising and I had never done
that but if since love that and loved
doing that in films like theory of
everything bringing the spontaneous and
in terms and not always sticking to the
scripts because you can get something
more interesting sometimes before that
you had done a lot of television in
England but not so many films correct
yeah yes was he taking a chance on you
Drake in a way definitely I
yeah a hundred percent I actually I read
the script and it was one of those
experiences where I just I just knew
100% I had to do it which doesn't always
happen you know sometimes you have
doubts about saying but with this it was
absolutely just felt so right I like
there was such honesty in it and and
then I spoke to Drake on the phone and
we had such similar tastes and he said
would you just make an audition tape and
then I made that and I didn't so I
didn't meet Drake until I flew out and I
remember coming to the airport and Los
Angeles and you know it's a low-budget
film so he kindly came and picked me up
and we went had dinner and we're like
right this is it this is where we start
making the film so it was all it's very
much driven on instinct really it he he
definitely took a chance on me well
we're gonna look at one scene from the
theory of everything this to me is the
most emotional moment that I can recall
in the film this is when your character
Jane sees her husband Stephen Hawking
really for the first time after he's had
surgery - well he's just had the
tracheal to me so he's no longer no
longer speak so this is your attempt to
communicate with him through this letter
board and she seems quite nervous about
it so let's take a look at this scene
together and we'll talk about
this is spelling board
firstly you tell me what letter you want
by blinking when I say the color of the
group that contains the letter once I
knew the group you can choose the
character inside that group by blinking
again when I say the color of each
letter within that group now one thing I
was struck by when I watched this film
for the first time is that Jane is such
a confident woman but her voice is
quivering in this moment she's so
unusual yes well it's it's two things
it's firstly the idea that Stephen
Hawking her husband who's this
incredible mind and man can no longer
use his voice anymore and that idea of
losing that part of your identity is
just his art is horrific and she doesn't
want to show him how emotional she is
because it's not about her she was a
good bad things exactly so she's trying
to hold it hold his head yeah and trying
to just okay we're gonna get through
this I'm gonna we're gonna find
something this is not going to be a
problem yeah let's see how it goes
apparently let's just try
Green
blue pink
black
red
I mean in instantly you see on your face
her face she knows this is not going
well well she knows how ridiculous it is
you know who she's hauling up the stupid
board I mean that's not gonna do any are
you supposed to communicate all your
feelings and thoughts so that silly
board and she knows that it she knows
that it's it's so inadequate well let's
keep going blink to choose the colors
the group of the letter you want Steven
I remember at this point watching the
film thinking to myself I really put
myself in his shoes at this point if I
were in this position what would I even
begin to think of saying how would I
even start to use this board it just
would be completely overwhelming I'm
what was so amazing about Stephen and
Edie playing him is that Stephen even
when his voice cuz the disease was
affecting his voice and it was Impala it
was so hard for him to speak and it came
out in this very strange tone and for
ages he was speaking at almost this
quite squeaky voice but Stephens
resilience was that he just persisted
until the very last point until he
finally couldn't speak anymore he's lost
at this moment he's like how how do i
how do i navigate this this is one of
those things that is almost
insurmountable it's so much despair and
it continues Greene you
pink
Brett
it's amazing to me how just a line of
five words five colors can have such a
strong impact well I think I felt that
she she feels like if I can't make this
work I'm worried our marriage is over
this is her fighting for the
relationship to continue as well which
they've done they said they've survived
so many hurdles before and she's
determined that they're gonna get
through this one but is this the one
that's gonna go it's gonna break them
apart now I love the last 25 30 seconds
of this scene because there's no more
words but it's still such a beautiful
and powerful moment
you and Eddie have known each other for
many years before you made this film
what was it like once you've finished
this shooting day and you finished doing
the scene however many times you did it
I think we had about five more scenes to
do because it was quite a jam-packed
schedule so we would just we that day I
think we were then jumping back to being
um when when one of the scenes when they
first met so it was so then we had to go
you know go back in time and and
remember who these people were when they
were sort of young and didn't know what
was that what was ahead of them now that
you've finished this process what is
your bond like with Eddie he's a great
friend and yeah you don't go through you
don't make something like this without
having a lasting friendship afterwards
yeah I can see why it's a powerful scene
so I really appreciate you talking to us
about it thank you very much well
Felicity thanks so much for your time
today I really appreciate it and thanks
to the AMC Century City theatres for
having us today if you haven't yet
checked out the theory of everything be
sure to see Felicity's fantastic
performance and thanks so much for
watching
Fandango frontrunner to show our
appreciation for you joining us today
we've made you your very own Fandango
Gifford
thank you very much so now you have to
take your photo with me this is very
high-tech one two three
the whole selling machine great